spirituality
is a particular term
which actually means
are dealing with
intuition
in the theistic tradition
there is notion of clinging into a word
a certain Act is regarded as
a displeasing
to a Divine principles
and certain actors regard as a pleasing
for the Divine whatever
in the tradition of a non-theism however
it is very direct
that the case history are not
particularly important
what is actually important is here and
now here
now it's definitely now
we try to experience what is available
there on the spot
there's no point in thinking that the
past did exist that we could have now
this is now
this very moment
nothing Mr Gold just now very simple
straightforward
and from that now in this Harbor
arises
a sense of intelligence always
that you are constantly interacting with
the reality
one by one spot by spot constantly
we actually experience a fantastic
Precision always
but we are threatened by the now
so we jump to the past or the future
paying attention to
the materials that exist in our life
all these choices takes place all the
time
but none of them regarded as a bad or
good per se everything we experience are
unconditional experience they don't come
along with the label by saying this
regardless of bad this is good
but we experienced that but we don't
actually pay heed to them
properly
we don't actually regard that is that we
are going somewhere regard that is
hassle
waiting to be dead
waiting to be dead
that's the problem
and that is not trusting the narrowness
properly that what is actual experience
now possessed a lot of powerful things
it is so powerful
that we can't face it
therefore we have to borrow from the
past invite the future all the time
and maybe that's why we seek religion
religion maybe that's why we March in
the street
maybe that's why we complain to the
society
maybe that's why we vote for the
presidents foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the more you begin to investigate
what we think we understand where we
came from what we think we're doing
the more you begin to see we've been
lied to
we've been lied to by every institution
what makes you think for one minute that
the religious institution is the only
one that's never been touched the
religious institutions of this world are
at the bottom
of the dirt
the religious institutions in this world
are put there by the same people who
gave you your government your corrupt
education to set up your International
banking cartels
we have been misled away from the true
and divine presence in the universe that
men have called God I don't know what
God is but I know what he isn't
and unless and until you are prepared
to look at the whole truth and wherever
it may go whoever it may lead to
the more you educate yourself the more
you understand where things come from
the more obvious Things become and you
begin to see lies everywhere you have to
know the truth and seek the truth and
the truth will set you free
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
when it comes to [ __ ]
Big Time Major League [ __ ] you have
to stand in awe of the all-time champion
of false promises and exaggerating
claims religion
think about it religion has actually
convinced people
that there's an invisible man
living in the sky he watches everything
you do every minute of every day and the
Invisible Man Has a special list of 10
things he does not want you to do and if
you do any of these 10 things he has a
special place full of fire and smoke and
burning and torture and anguish where he
will send you to live and suffer and
burn and choke and scream and cry
forever and ever till the end of time
but he loves you
[Applause]
he loves you and he needs money
he always needs money he's all powerful
all perfect all-knowing and all wise
somehow just can't handle money
religion takes in billions of dollars
they pay no taxes and they always need a
little more now you talk about a good
[ __ ] story
holy [ __ ]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Sun
as far back as 10 000 BC history is
abundant with carvings and writings
reflecting people's respect and
adoration for this object
and it is simple to understand why as
every morning as someone rise bringing
Vision warmth and security saving man
from the cold blind predator-filled
darkness of night
without it the culture's understood the
crops would not grow and life on the
planet would not survive
these realities made the Sun the most
adored object of all time
likewise they were also very aware of
the Stars
the tracking of the Stars allowed them
to recognize and anticipate events which
occurred over long periods of time such
as eclipses and full moons
they in turn catalog Celestial groups
into what we know today as
constellations
this is the cross of the zodiac one of
the oldest conceptual images in human
history it reflects the Sun as it
figuratively passes through the 12 major
constellations over the course of a year
it also reflects the 12 months of the
year the Four Seasons and the solstices
and equinoxes
from zodiac relates to the fact that
constellations were anthropomorphized or
personified as figures or animals
in other words the early civilizations
did not just follow the sun and stars
they personified them with elaborate
myths involving their movements and
relationships
the sun with his life-giving and saving
qualities was personified as a
representative of the Unseen Creator or
God God's son the light of the world the
savior of humankind
likewise the 12 constellations
represented places of travel for God's
son and were identified by names usually
representing elements of nature that
happened during that period of time for
example Aquarius the water Bearer who
brings the spring Reigns
[Music]
this is Horus
he is the sun god of Egypt of around
3000 BC he is the son anthropomorphized
in his life is a series of allegorical
myths involving the sun's movement in
the sky
from the ancient hieroglyphics in Egypt
we know much about the solar Messiah
for instance Horus being the Sun or the
light had an enemy known as set in set
was the personification of the darkness
or night
and metaphorically speaking every
morning Horus would win the battle
against set while in the evening set
would conquer Horus and send him into
the underworld
it is important to note that dark versus
light or good versus evil is one of the
most ubiquitous mythological dualities
ever known and is still expressed on
many levels to this day
[Music]
broadly speaking the story of Horus is
as follows
Chris was born on December 25th of the
Virgin Isis Mary his birth was
accompanied by a star in the east and
upon his birth he was adored by Three
Kings
at the age of 12 he was a prodigal child
teacher at the age of 30 he was baptized
by a figure known as Anup and thus began
his ministry Horus had 12 disciples he
traveled about with performing Miracles
such as Healing The Sick and walking on
water
Horus was known by many gestural names
such as the truth the light God's
anointed Sun the Good Shepherd the Lamb
of God and many others
after being betrayed by Typhon Horus was
crucified buried for three days and thus
Resurrected
these attributes of Horus whether
original or not seem to permeate many
cultures of the world for many other
gods are found to have the same general
mythological structure
Addis of phrygia born in the Virgin Nana
on December 25th crucified placed in a
tomb and after three days was
resurrected
Krishna of India born of the Virgin
devaki with a star in the east signaling
his coming he performed Miracles with
his disciples and upon his death was
resurrected
dionyses of Greece born of a virgin on
December 25th was a traveling teacher
who performed Miracles such as turning
water into wine he was referred to as
the King of Kings God's only begotten
son the Alpha and Omega and many others
and upon his death he was resurrected
Mithra of Persia born of a virgin on
December 25th he had 12 disciples and
performed Miracles and upon his death
was buried for three days and thus
resurrected he was also referred to as
the truth the light and many others
interestingly the sacred day of worship
of Mithra was Sunday
to the matter is there are numerous
saviors from different periods from all
over the world which subscribe to these
general characteristics
the question remains why are these
attributes
why the Virgin birth on December 25th
why dad for three days in the inevitable
Resurrection why 12 disciples are
followers
to find out let's examine the most
recent of the solar Messiahs
[Music]
Jesus Christ was born of the Virgin Mary
on December 25th in Bethlehem his birth
was announced by a star in the east
which Three Kings or Magi followed to
locate and Adorn the new savior he was a
child teacher at 12 at the age of 30 he
was baptized by John the Baptist and
thus began his ministry
Jesus had 12 disciples which he traveled
about with performing Miracles such as
Healing The Sick walking on water
raising the dead he was also known as
the King of Kings the Son of God the
light of the world the Alpha and Omega
the Lamb of God and many many others
after being betrayed by his disciple
Judas and sold for 30 pieces of silver
he was crucified placing it to him and
after three days was resurrected and
ascended into heaven
first of all the birth sequence is
completely astrological
the star in the east is serious the
brightest star in the night sky which on
December 24th aligns with the three
brightest stars in Orion's Belt these
three bright stars in Orion's Belt are
called today what they were called in
ancient times the the three kings and
the three kings and the brightest star
Sirius all point to the place of the
sunrise on December 25th this is why the
three kings follow the star in the east
in order to locate the sunrise
the birth of the Sun
[Music]
the Virgin Mary is the constellation
Virgo also known as Virgo the Virgin
Virgo in Latin means virgin
Burger was also referred to as the house
of bread and the representation of Virgo
is a virgin holding a Sheaf of wheat
this house of bread and its symbol of
wheat represents August and September
the time of harvest in turn Bethlehem in
fact literally translates to House of
Bread Bethlehem is thus a reference to
the constellation of Virgo a place in
the sky not on Earth
there is another very interesting
phenomenon that occurs around December
25th or the winter solstice from the
summer solstice to the winter solstice
the days become shorter and colder and
from the perspective of the northern
hemisphere the Sun appears to move South
and get smaller and more scarce the
shortening of the days and the
expiration of the crops When approaching
the winter solstice symbolize the
process of death to the ancients
it was the death of the Sun
and by December 22nd the sun's demise
was fully realized for the sun having
moved South continually for six months
makes it to its lowest point in the sky
here a Curious Thing occurs
the sun stops moving south
at least perceivably for three days and
during this three-day pause the sun
resides in the vicinity of the Southern
Cross or Crux constellation
and after this time on December 25th the
sun moves one degree this time North
foreshadowing longer days warmth and
spring
and thus it was said
the sun died on the cross was dead for
three days only to be resurrected or
born again
this is why Jesus and numerous other Sun
Gods share the crucifixion three-day
death and Resurrection concept
it is the sun's transition period before
it shifts its direction back into the
northern hemisphere bringing spring and
thus salvation
however they did not celebrate the
resurrection of the sun until the spring
equinox or Easter
this is because at the Spring Equinox
the sun officially overpowers the evil
Darkness as daytime thereafter becomes
longer in duration than the night and
the revitalizing conditions of spring
emerge
now probably the most obvious of all the
astrological symbolism Around Jesus
regards the Twelve Disciples they are
simply the 12 constellations of the
zodiac which Jesus being the son travels
about with
foreign
in fact the number 12 is replete
throughout the Bible
coming back to the cross of the zodiac
the figurative life of the sun this was
not just an artistic expression or tool
to track the sun's movement it was also
a pagan spiritual symbol the shorthand
of which looked like this
this is not a symbol of Christianity
it is a pagan adaptation of the Cross of
the zodiac
[Music]
this is why Jesus in early occult art is
always shown with his head on the cross
for Jesus is the son
the Son of God the light of the world
the Risen Savior who will come again as
it does every morning the glory of God
who defends against the works of
darkness as he is born again every
morning and can be seen coming in the
clouds
up in heaven
with his crown of thorns or sun rays
now of the many astrological
astronomical metaphors in the Bible one
of the most important has to do with the
ages
throughout the scriptures there are
numerous references to the age in order
to understand this we need to be
familiar with the phenomenon known as
the procession of the equinoxes
the ancient Egyptians along with
cultures long before them recognized
that approximately every 2150 years the
sunrise on the morning of the Spring
Equinox would occur at a different sign
of the zodiac
this has to do with a slow angular
wobble that the Earth maintains as it
rotates on its axis
it is called A procession because the
constellations go backwards rather than
through the normal yearly cycle
the amount of time it takes for the
procession to go through all 12 signs is
roughly 25
765 years this is also called the great
year
then ancient societies were very aware
of this and they referred to each
2150-year period as an age
from 4300 BC to 2150 BC it was the age
of Taurus the Bull from 2150 BC to 180
it was the age of Aries the RAM and from
one A.D to 2150 A.D it is the age of
Pisces the age we are still into this
day
and in and around 2150 we will enter the
New Age The Age of Aquarius
now the Bible reflects broadly speaking
a symbolic movement through Three Ages
while foreshadowing a fourth in the Old
Testament when Moses comes down Mount
Sinai with the Ten Commandments he is
very upset to see his people worshiping
a Golden Bull calf
in fact he shattered the stone tablets
and instructed his people to kill each
other in order to purify themselves most
biblical Scholars will attribute this
anger to the fact that the Israelites
were worshiping a false idol or
something to that effect the reality is
the Golden Bull is Taurus the Bull and
Moses represents the new age of Ares the
ran
this is why Jews even today still blow
the Ram's Horn Moses represents the new
age of Aries and upon the new age
everyone must shed the old age
other deities Mark these transitions as
well such as Mithra a pre-christian God
who kills the bull in the same symbology
now Jesus is the figure who ushers in
the age following Aries the age of
Pisces or the two fish
fish symbolism is very abundant in the
New Testament Jesus feeds five thousand
people with bread and two fish
when he begins his ministry walking
along Galilee he befriends to fishermen
who follow him
and I think we have all seen the Jesus
fish on the back of people's cars little
do they know what it actually means
it is a pagan astrological symbolism for
the sun's Kingdom during the age of
Pisces
also Jesus's assumed birth date is
essentially the start of this age
at Luke 22 10 when Jesus is asked by his
disciples where the last passover would
be Jesus replies
behold when ye are entered into the city
there shall a man meet you bearing a
pitcher of water follow him into the
house where he entereth in
this scripture is by far one of the most
revealing of all the astrological
references
the man bearing the picture of water is
Aquarius the water Bearer who is always
pictured as a man pouring out a pitcher
of water
he represents the age after Pisces and
when the son God's son leaves the age of
Pisces Jesus it will go into the house
of Aquarius as Aquarius follows Pisces
in the procession of the equinoxes all
Jesus is saying is that after the age of
Pisces will come the age of Aquarius
foreign
now we have all heard about the end
times in the end of the world
the cartoonish depictions in the Book of
Revelation aside the main source of this
idea comes from Matthew 28 20 where
Jesus says I will be with you even to
the end of the world
however in the King James version world
is a mistranslation among many
mistranslations
the actual word being used is eon
which means age
I will be with you even to the End of
the Age which is true as Jesus's solar
piscean personification will end when
the sun enters the age of Aquarius the
entire concept of end times in the end
of the world is a misinterpreted
astrological allegory let's tell that to
the approximately 100 million people in
America who believe the end of the world
is coming
furthermore the character of Jesus being
a literary and astrological hybrid is
most explicitly a plagiarization of the
Egyptian sun god Horus for example
inscribed about 3 500 years ago on the
walls at the Temple of Luxor in Egypt
are images of the Annunciation the
miracle conception the birth and the
Adoration of Horus the images begin with
Thoth announced into the Virgin ises
that she will conceive for us then neth
the Holy Ghost impregnating the virgin
and then the Virgin birth and the
Adoration
this is exactly the story of Jesus's
Miracle conception
in fact the literary similarities
between the Egyptian religion and the
Christian religion are staggering
and the plagiarism is continuous the
story of Noah and Noah's Ark is taken
directly from tradition the concept of
the great flood is ubiquitous throughout
the ancient world with over 200 cited
claims in different periods and times
however one need looked no further for a
pre-christian source than the Epic of
Gilgamesh written in 2600 BC
this story talks of a great flood
commanded by God an ark with saved
animals upon it and even the release and
return of a dove all held in common with
the biblical story among many other
similarities
and then there is the plagiarized story
of Moses upon Moses's birth it is said
that he was placed in a reed basket and
set adrift in a river in order to avoid
infanticide
he was later rescued by a daughter of
royalty and raised by her as a prince
this baby in a basket story was lifted
directly from the myth of Sargon of a
cot of around 2250 BC
Sargon was born placed in a reed Basket
in order to avoid infanticide and set
adrift in a river he was in turn rescued
and raised by a key a royal Midwife
furthermore Moses is known as the law
Giver The Giver of the Ten Commandments
the Mosaic law however the idea of a law
being passed from God to a prophet up on
a mountain is also a very old motif
Moses is just another lawgiver in a long
line of law givers in mythological
history in India Manu was the great
lawgiver in Crete Minos ascended Mount
dicta where Zeus gave him the sacred
laws while in Egypt there was mises who
carried stone tablets and upon them the
laws of God were written
Manu Minos mises Moses
and as far as the Ten Commandments they
are taken outright from spell 125 in the
Egyptian Book of the Dead what the Book
of the Dead phrased I have not stolen
became thou shall not steal I have not
killed became thou shall not kill I have
not told lies became Thou shalt not bear
false witness and so forth in fact the
Egyptian religion is likely the primary
foundational basis for the
judeo-christian theology baptism
afterlife final judgment virgin birth
death and Resurrection crucifixion the
Ark of the Covenant circumcision saviors
Holy Communion great flood Easter
Christmas Passover and many many more
are all attributes of Egyptian ideas
long predating Christianity and Judaism
Justin Martyr one of the first Christian
historians and Defenders wrote
when we say that he Jesus Christ our
teacher was produced without sexual
Union was crucified and died and rose
again and ascended into heaven we
propound nothing different from what you
believe regarding those who you esteem
sons of Jupiter
in a different writing Justin Martyr
said he was born of a virgin except this
in common with what you believe of
Perseus
it's obvious that Justin and other early
Christians knew how similar Christianity
was to the Pagan religions however
Justin had a solution
as far as he was concerned
the devil did it
the devil had the foresight to come
before Christ and create his
characteristics in the Pagan world
fascinating these people actually
believe the world is 12 000 years old
I actually asked one of these guys okay
dinosaur fossils he says
dinosaur fossils God put those here to
test our faith
I think God put you here to test my
faith dude
the Bible is nothing more than an
astrotheological literary hybrid just
like nearly all religious myths before
it in fact the aspect of transference of
one character's attributes to a new
character can be found within the book
itself in the Old Testament there is the
story of Joseph Joseph was a prototype
for Jesus
Joseph was born of a miracle birth Jesus
was born of a miracle birth Joseph was
of 12 Brothers Jesus had 12 disciples
Joseph was sold for 20 pieces of silver
Jesus was sold for 30 pieces of silver
brother Judah suggests the sale of
Joseph disciple Judas suggests the sale
of Jesus
Joseph began his work at the age of 30.
Jesus began his work at the age of 30.
the parallels go on and on
furthermore is there any non-biblical
historical evidence of any person living
with the name Jesus the son of Mary who
traveled about with 12 followers healing
people and the like there are numerous
historians who lived in and around the
Mediterranean either during or soon
after the assumed life of Jesus
how many of these historians document
this figure
not one
however to be fair that doesn't mean
Defenders of the historical Jesus
haven't claimed the contrary four
historians are typically referenced to
justify Jesus's existence Pliny the
Younger satonius and tacitus are the
first three each one of their entries
consists of only a few sentences at best
and only referred to Priestess or the
Christ which in fact is not a name but a
title it means the anointed one
the fourth source is Josephus and this
Source has been proven to be a forgery
for hundreds of years sadly it is still
cited as truth
you would think that a guy who rose from
the dead and ascended into heaven for
all eyes to see and perform the wealth
of Miracles acclaimed to him would have
made it into the historical record it
didn't because once the evidence is
weighed there are very high odds that
the figure known as Jesus did not even
exist
we don't want to be unkind
but we want to be factual
we don't want to cause hurt feelings
but we want to be academically correct
and what we understand and know to be
true
Christianity just is not based on truth
we find that Christianity was in fact
nothing more than a Roman story
developed politically
the reality is Jesus was the solar deity
of the Gnostic Christian sect
and like all other pagan gods he was a
mythical figure
it was the political establishment that
sought to historize the Jesus figure for
social control
in 325 A.D in Rome emperor Constantine
convened the Council of nicer it was
during this meeting that the politically
motivated Christian doctrines were
established and thus began a long
history of religious Bloodshed and
spiritual fraud and for over the next
one thousand years the Vatican
maintained a political Stranglehold on
all of Europe leading to such joyous
periods as the Dark Ages along with
enlightening events such as the Crusades
and the Inquisition
foreign
Ty along with all other related
theologies is an historical fraud
these religions now serve to detach the
species from the natural world and
likewise each other they support blind
submission to Authority they reduce
human responsibility to the effect that
God controls everything and in turn
awful crimes can be justified in the
name of a Divine Pursuit
and most critically it empowers the
political establishment who have been
using the myth to manipulate and control
societies
the religious myth is one of the most
powerful devices ever created and it
serves as the psychological soil upon
which other myths can flourish
[Music]
a myth is an idea that while widely
believed is false
in a deeper sense
in the religious sense
a myth serves as an orienting and
mobilizing story for a people
the focus is not on the story's relation
to reality but on its function
a story cannot function
unless it is believed to be true in the
community or the nation
it is not a matter of debate if some
people have the bad taste to raise the
question of the truth of the Sacred
Story the keepers of the faith do not
enter into debate with them they ignore
them or denounce them as blasphemers it
is wrong Blasphemous and sinful for you
to suggest imply or help other people
come to the conclusion that the U.S
government killed three thousand of its
own citizens
foreign
[Music]
it looks like one of those scenes of an
old building being purposely dynamated
and blown up anybody who's ever watched
a building being demolished on purpose
knows that if you're going to do this
you have to get at the under
infrastructure of a building and bring
it down the way the structure is
collapsing this was the result of
something that was planned it's not
accidental that the first Tower just
happened to collapse and then the second
hour just happened to collapse in
exactly the same way how they
accomplished this we don't know the
building collapsed to dust
you don't find a desk
you don't find a chair
you don't find a telephone a computer
the biggest piece of a telephone I found
was half of the keypad and it was about
this big what happened to the car
concrete was pulverized from River to
River there was exhaust powder two three
inches thick the concrete was just uh
pulverized some addition to those
pictures we've all seen
Dynamite to knock it down
[Music]
to me it sounded like an explosion to
sound like gunfire
and then all of a sudden three big
explosions and we heard a big explosion
coming down and then the entire top of
the building just blew up we saw some
kind of explosion by the fourth of the
explosions big explosion blew us back
into the eighth floor then we get to the
lodge
a lot of people preserve a bomb had
exploded there a huge explosion now
reigning debris it's been a huge
explosion huge explosion that we all
heard and felt we just witnessed some
kind of follow-up explosion we heard a
very loud
explosion
that is another bomb going off he thinks
that there were actually devices that
were planted in the building planted in
the building
[Music]
I don't think anybody could have
predicted that they would try to use an
airplane as a missile a hijacked
airplane as a missile nobody in our
government at least and I don't think
the prior government that could Envision
flying airplanes into buildings those no
specific threat involving really
domestic operation or involving what
happened obviously yeah the city's
airliner and so there I were no warning
signs that I'm aware of
[Music]
in confidential documents from the
Philippines obtained by CNN the plan was
clear he will board any American
Commercial aircraft control its cockpit
and dive it at the CIA headquarters
other buildings targeted the Pentagon
and the World Trade Center the Federal
Aviation Administration received 52
warnings about Al Qaeda in the six
months before 9 11 and did not
apparently heed them Pentagon reportedly
does not want the public to hear next
week's Senate testimony about the former
secret intelligence unit known as able
danger and it identified Muhammad Atta
and three other 9 11 terrorist members
of an Al-Qaeda cell in Brooklyn New York
more than a year before the attacks and
we found two of the three cells which
conducted 911 attacks the tenant Colonel
Tony Schaefer who was the first member
of able danger to go public has now been
told in writing by the defense
intelligence agency that he can't speak
to members of Congress or their staff
without prior approval security
encounter terrorism was blinking red in
the words of George Tennant that the
warnings of an imminent attack were so
severe that something dramatic should
have been done it was unparalleled
instead our president went on a
month-long vacation
[Music]
the head of Pakistani intelligence of
the isi Mahmoud Ahmed requested Omar
Sheikh to wire a hundred thousand
dollars to Muhammad Atta who was the
lead hijacker did hijacker Muhammad Atta
received wire transfers via Pakistan the
man sending the money to Atta is
believed to be Ahmed Umar Saeed Sheikh
Omar Sheikh admitted he was supported by
the Pakistan government's intelligence
service the isi
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as hard as this is to believe that two
of the alleged terrorists involved in
what happened on Tuesday May have
attended schools run by the U.S military
evidence was also apparently planted the
passport of one of the hijackers on
flight 11 was allegedly found in the
rebel the hijackers passport was found
blocks from the World Trade Center crash
site if you can believe that the 911
hijackers are alive and well that's
according to the chief of Japan's
Democratic party who says 911 is a hoax
several of these 19 men are still alive
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
of course we're after Saddam Hussein I
mean uh Bin Laden he's he's in the early
1980s Bin Laden worked with operatives
from U.S intelligence the Pakistani
military and Arab states January 2001
the bushes
orders the FBI
intelligence
instigations involving the bin Laden
family including two of Osama bin
Laden's relatives who were living guess
where in Falls Church Virginia right
next to CIA headquarters when he was
already America's most wanted criminal
he reportedly spent two weeks in the
American Hospital in Dubai was treated
by an American doctor and visited by the
local CIA agent we have not seen one
piece of evidence that links Osama Bin
Laden directly to the planning stages of
September 11th this failure to provide
proof was later said to be unnecessary
because Bin Laden in a video allegedly
found in Afghanistan admitted
responsibility for the attacks
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
1976 osama's older brother Saleem bin
Laden
hired a man in Texas by the name of Jim
bath to handle all the investments in
the United States for the bin Laden
family Jim bath also happens to be a
personal almost lifelong friend and
former Air National Guard pilot with
George W bush the connections between
the bushes and the bin ladens become
much more clear when George Herbert
Walker Bush made trips to Saudi Arabia
in 1998 and 2000 to meet with the bin
Laden family on behalf of a company
called the Carlisle Group
foreign
[Music]
how could anyone fly a 60-ton 125 foot
wide 44 foot tall plane through this
obstacle course the aircraft before
striking the Pentagon reportedly
executed a 270 degree downward spiral
and yet honey on youer was known as a
terrible pilot who could not safely fly
even a small plane
foreign
luggage no bodies nothing but bricks and
Limestone the official explanation is
that the intense heat from the jet fuel
vaporized the entire plane flight 77 had
two Rolls-Royce and engines made of
steel and titanium alloy and weighs 6
tons each it is scientifically
impossible but 12 tons of steel and
titanium was vaporized by jet fuel we're
also told that the bodies were able to
be identified
either by their fingerprints or by the
DNA so what kind of fire can vaporize
aluminum and tempered steel
and yet leave leave human bodies intact
from my close-up inspection there's no
evidence of a plane having crashed
anywhere near the Pentagon and as I said
the only pieces left that you can see
are are small enough that you could pick
up in your hand shortly after the strike
government agents picked up debris and
carried it off the entire lawn was
covered with dirt and gravel so that any
remaining forensic evidence was
literally covered up the videos from
security cameras which would show what
really hit the Pentagon were immediately
confiscated by agents of the FBI and the
Department of Justice has to this day
refuse to release them
if these videos would prove that the
Pentagon was really hit by a 757 most of
us would assume the government would
release them
it looks like there's nothing there
except for a hole in the ground uh
basically that's right the only thing
you could see from where we were was a
big gouge in the earth and some broken
trees we could see some people working
walking around in the area but from
where we could see there wasn't much
left any large pieces of debris at all
no there was nothing nothing that you
could distinguish that a plane had
crashed there
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the FBI and the state police here have
confirmed that they have cordoned off a
second area about six to eight miles
away from the crater here this is
apparently another debris site
why would debris be located six miles
away could it have blown that far away
seems highly unlikely
foreign
According to which the fires while not
melting the steel heated it up
sufficiently to cause the floors
weakened by the airplane strikes to
break loose from the steel columns and
this started a chain reaction so you
would expect then from that theory which
is the official Theory to see a whole
stack of floors piled up on top of each
other and then a spindle of core columns
standing too the core of each of the
Twin Towers consisted of 47 massive
steel columns if the floors had broken
loose from them these columns would have
still been sticking up into the air a
thousand feet the plane did not cut all
those core columns we designed the
buildings to take the impact of the
Boeing 707
uh hitting the building at any location
the building probably could sustain
multiple impacts of jetliners that the
plane
[Music]
so you're saying that the building was
actually designed to cope with a hole
like that and then still survive yeah it
was it was if you had dropped say a
billiard ball from the top of the World
Trade Center 110 floors up there it
would have taken 8 to 10 seconds to hit
the ground encountering no resistance
whatsoever the Twin Towers came down in
nearly Free Fall speed 200 000 tons of
steel shatters and explodes outwards
over 500 feet this means that floors
shattered at an average rate of about 10
floors per second there is no scenario
for a pancake effect of buildings
falling that allows them to fall at the
rate of Free Fall now what can do that
what what can move Mass out of the way
explosives
47 huge steel columns going up the core
they're interconnected
how do you get them to fail
simultaneously so the cord is pierced it
looks like those core columns were cut
the way we do this is by cutting the
beam at an angle
I started looking at the molten metal
all three buildings both Towers in the
rubble in the basement areas and
building seven there's these pools of
molten metal
get down below and you'd see molten
steel
molten steel running down the channel
rails
like you're in a Foundry
the molten steel was found three four
and five weeks later when the rubble was
being removed he said that molten steel
was also found underneath World Trade
Center 7. so I'm looking through the
official reports what do they say about
the molten metal they say nothing
but wait a minute this is important
evidence to where'd that come from
thermite is so hot that it'll just cut
through steel through structural steel
for example like a knife through butter
the products are molten iron and
aluminum oxide which goes off primarily
as a dust
you know those enormous dust clouds you
can imagine when you assemble these
chemicals on a large scale
so Professor Niels herritt you examined
the rubble that came from the World
Trade Center what did you find in it
well in there we find remains of what we
characterize as a thematic material
and this is a very energetic material
which can be used either for melting
iron or it can be designed as an
explosive the evidence for control
demolition is overwhelming I've told you
that the thermite reaction produced
molten Iron Mountain Iron was in pools
of mountain iron under in the rubble and
and the point is that the thermite kept
on reacting this was a [ __ ] Brew of
thermite chemistry molten metal pools
under both Towers after they collapsed
and building seven now building seven
wasn't even hit by a jet
part of the problem is that most people
simply don't know much about building
seven due to the extraordinary secrecy
surrounding this collapse this was a 47
story skyscraper this building fell at 5
25 it was not hit by a plane
this building had fires on only two or
three floors and it was brought down by
what we know was a controlled demolition
demolitions they look just like that
kink in the middle and then that
building just comes straight down almost
at Free Fall speed
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
was on the B1 level as I was talking to
a supervisor at 846 and all the sudden
we hear Boom
an explosion so hard that push us
upwards
and it came from the basement between
the B2 level and the B3 level and when I
went to verbalize we hear Boom
the impact of the plane on the top
it would appear too as if there's more
smoke coming from the ground I was down
in the basement came down all of a
sudden the elevator blew up and as we
were coming out we passed the lobby
there was no Lobby so I believe the bomb
hit the lobby first and a couple of
seconds in the first plane hit as I'm
walking by the main freight car of the
building in the corridor
that's that's when I got blown I mean
the impact of the explosion threw me to
the floor and that's when everything
started happening what was sudden the
big impact happen again
and all the ceiling tile was falling
down the light fixtures were falling you
know you got to go clear across the hole
from one to one to two World Trade
Center and then all of a sudden it
happened all over again so that melts
hit us to the floor right in the
basement you felt it walls were caving
in everything that was going on I mean I
know people that got killed in the
basement I know people that got broken
legs in it in the basement people got
reconstructive for surgery because the
walls hit him in the face
foreign
[Music]
to Standard Operating procedure if an
FAA flight controller notices anything
that suggests a possible hijacking
controllers to contact the superior if
the problem cannot be fixed within about
a minute the superior status NORAD the
North American Aerospace command to send
up or scramble jet fighters to find out
what is going on Norad then issues the
scramble order to the nearest Air Force
base with fighters on alert but although
interceptions usually occur within 10 or
so minutes in this case 80 or so minutes
had elapsed before Fighters were even
Airborne it's a mind-bending anomaly not
a single U.S Air Force Interceptor turns
a wheel until it's too late there are no
Jets at all what if they were so
confused and had been so deliberately
confused that they couldn't respond the
reason that they didn't know where to go
was because a number of conflicting and
overlapping war game exercises were
taking place that involved the insertion
of false radar blips onto radar screens
in the Northeast air defense sector we
have a problem here we have a hijacked
aircraft headed towards New York we need
somewhat describing there's something up
there to help us out is this real world
or exercise is this real world or
exercise there was another exercise
Vigilant Warrior which was in fact
according to a NORAD Source a live fly
hijacked drill being conducted at the
same time with only eight available
fighter aircraft and they have to be
dispatched in pairs they were dealing
with as many as 22 possible hijacks on
the day of 911 and they couldn't
separate the war game exercises from the
actual hijacks
foreign
[Music]
government has not been able to
determine the origin of the money used
for the 9 11 attacks ultimately the
question is of little practical
significance the American authorities
have not managed to trace the source of
the funding and then the most amazingly
disingenuous statement ultimately is it
of little consequence it is a massive
consequence doesn't it matter who paid
for 9 11 the collapse of building 7 has
been recognized as especially difficult
to explain
the 911 Commission report implicitly
admitted that it could not explain the
collapse of this building
by not even mentioning it why are you
and the vice president insisting on
appearing together before the 9 11
Commission because the land commission
911 Commission wants to ask us questions
that's why we're meeting and I look
forward to meeting with them and
answering their questions
why you're appearing together rather
than separately which was their request
because it's a good chance for both of
us to answer questions that the 911
Commission is looking forward to asking
us and I'm looking forward to answering
them
let's see do you think they should be
able to stand up and and speak their own
words they should go under oath they
should be yeah in public
[Music]
don't you think that the families
deserve to have a transcript or to be
able to see what if you asked me that
question yesterday I got the same answer
yeah
the final report was a unanimous report
that means that if there was a single
commissioner who had any objection about
anything that fact would be dropped from
the report we have found out
that not only served on the transition
team of the Bush Administration that he
was a person who wrote a draft memo for
the setup of the Bush administration's
National Security Council that he was an
individual who wrote the preemptive war
strategy that was eventually used for
the war in Iraq that he is a close
friend of Condoleezza Rice's
him to resign there was literally
nothing in the 911 report that the Bush
Administration did not approve of we can
understand therefore why the commission
under zelichau's leadership would have
ignored all the evidence that would
point to the truth that 9 11 was a false
flag operation intended to authorize the
doctrines and funds needed for a new
level of Imperial mobilization
[Music]
armed with knives armed with chemical
biological nuclear weapons Fanatics
terrorist number 11 September 11th
killer September 11th terrorists of Al
Qaeda nuclear weapons terrorists 911
terrorists war and danger September 11th
terrorism Global terrorism terrorism
terrorism terrorist terrorist terrorist
terrorist the terror terrorists
terrorist terrorism September 11 Global
terrorism terrorism terrorism September
11 World terrorism terrorism September
11 Global terrorism
weapons of mass destruction September
the 11th September the 11th terrorists
the evil terrorist terrorist terrorists
no terrorism the words are hypnotically
repeated terrorism terrorist terrorist
threat it and of course believed to be
linked to Al-Qaeda
but it's the so-called war on terrorism
that's in our faces practically 24 7 as
the inescapable focus of our existence
one day our grandchildren will look back
on this time and ask
how was the war on terror one the entire
U.S ruling class ruling Elite comes to
see terrorism as the preferred means
indeed the only means to provide social
cohesion to provide an enemy image for
the society to keep it together
according to neocon Theory from Carl
Schmidt you have to have an enemy image
in order to have a society it's a very
dangerous thing because now it means
that the entire social order the
political parties intellectual life
politics in general all based on a
monstrous myth monstrous myth
foreign
[Music]
most if not all of them we had the
Marine Barracks their Embassy in Kenya
you had Pan Am 103. we had the USS coal
we had Oklahoma City we had the World
Trade Center in 1993. that helped the
terrorists blow up the World Trade
Center the first time they built the
bomb they've got the driver's license
the informant yet performant thoning
Salam a 43 year old former Egyptian army
officer he was given the assignment to
put the bomb together and he went to his
supervisor his FBI supervisor and said
we're going to put a dummy bomb in here
right in the FBI supervisor said no
we're going to put a real bomb
FBI agents might have been able to
prevent last February's deadly explosion
at New York's World Trade Center they
discussed secretly substituting harmless
powder for the explosives but they
didn't according to the FBI's own
informant Imad Salem unbeknownst to the
FBI at the time Salem recorded many of
his conversations with his handlers
unfortunately for them
there were only six people killed not
enough to pass the legislation so what
happened is to you later April 19 1995
down comes Oklahoma City uh Murrah
building 168 people killed one year
later the anti-terrorism legislation
takes away any of our constitutional
rights and civil liberties is passed
[Applause]
because at office 9 this morning we were
actually running an exercise for over a
company of a thousand people in London
based on simultaneous bombs going off
precisely at the railway stations that
happened this morning so I still have
the hairs in the back of my legs
standing upright if you get this quite
straight you were running an exercise to
see where how you would cope with this
and it happened while you were running
the exercise precisely
foreign
there was also an anti-terrorist drill
going on on 7-7 and again just like 9 11
they were talking about attacks on the
same targets the same kind of tube
stations and exactly the same time as
the actual attack happened providing
some kind of cover for what must be
operations orchestrated in some way by
the state
foreign
[Applause]
I am absolutely appalled at how much
people in this country do not think
we are given to understand that that a
guy out there up in the mountains
financed the most elaborate attack on
this country
do you think some people in a cave were
able to have NORAD stand down do you
think that people in a cave were able to
have all of this happen and when I think
about how many Americans were killed in
New York City and believing as I do that
this thing was a setup job this is a
textbook operation that Nazis used and
they've used it over and over again
America has been suckered in one more
time
I don't have to tell you things are bad
everybody knows things are bad the
dollar buys a nickels worth banks are
going bus shopkeepers keep a gun under
the counter banks are running wild in
the street there's nobody anywhere seems
to know what to do and there's no end to
it
we know the air is unfit to breathe and
our food is unfit to eat we sit watching
our TVs while some local newscaster
tells us that today we had 15 homicides
of 63 violent crimes as if that's the
way it's supposed to be we know things
are bad worse than bad they're crazy
it's like everything everywhere is going
crazy so we don't go out anymore we sit
in the house and slowly the world we're
living in is getting smaller and all we
say is please at least leave us alone in
our living rooms let me have my toaster
and my TV and my steel belted radios and
I won't say anything just leave us alone
well I'm not going to leave you alone I
want you to get mad
I don't want you to protest I don't want
you to ride I don't want you to write to
your Congressman because I wouldn't know
what to tell you to write I don't know
what to do about the depression and the
inflation and the Russians and the crime
in the street all I know is that first
you've got to get mad you've got to say
I'm a human being God damn it my life
has value
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
Europe in 1939
it was realized
that the American people had no
intention of entering the war
but they believed that this country
could be enticed into the war
in very much the same way that it was
enticed into the last one
they planned first
to prepare the United States for foreign
war under the guise of American defense
second to involve Us in the war
step by step without our realization
third to create a series of incidents
which would force us into the actual
conflict
these plans were of course
to be covered and assisted by the full
power of their propaganda
our theaters soon became filled with
plays portraying the glory of War
of objectivity
and they have used the war
to justify the Restriction of
congressional power
and the Assumption of dictatorial
procedures on the part of the president
and his appointees
a fear campaign was inaugurated
we cannot allow the natural Passions
prejudices
of other peoples to lead our country to
destruction
thank you foreign
[Music]
the American Revolutionary War began as
the American colonies sought to detach
from England and its oppressive monarchy
the many reasons are cited for the
revolution one in particular sticks out
as a prime cause
that King George III of England outlawed
the interest-free independent currency
the colonies were producing themselves
in turn forcing them to borrow money
from the Central Bank of England
immediately creating economic hardship
and despair in the words of Peter Cooper
former vice president of the New York
Board of currency after Franklin had
explained to the British government as
the real cause of prosperity they
immediately passed laws forbidding the
payment of taxes in that money this
produced such great inconvenience and
misery to the people that it was the
principal cause of the revolution
in 1783 America won its independence
from England however its battle against
the Central Bank concept and the corrupt
power hungry mentality associated with
it had just begun
so what is a central bank
a central bank is an institution that
issues and regulates the currency of an
entire nation
based on historical precedent the
typical powers inherent in Central
Banking practice include the control of
interest rates and the expansion and
contraction of the money supply itself
now the Central Bank does not simply
issue money to the government it loans
it to them with interest then through
the mechanisms of increasing and
decreasing the supply of money the
Central Bank essentially regulates the
value of the currency issued
it is critical to understand that the
entire structure of this system could
only produce one thing in the long run
debt
it doesn't take a lot of Ingenuity to
figure this scam out for every single
dollar produced by both the central bank
and its regulated commercial Banks is
loaned at interest
that means every dollar produced is
actually the Dollar Plus a certain
percentage of debt based on that dollar
and since the banking system has the
Monopoly of the production of the
currency
and they loan each dollar out with an
immediate debt attached to it
where does the money to pay for the debt
come from
it can only come from the banks again
which means the banking system has to
perpetually increase its money supply to
temporarily cover the outstanding debt
created which in turn since that new
money is loaned out at interest as well
creates even more debt
the end result of this system is
essentially slavery for it is
technically impossible for the
government and thus the public to ever
come out of the self-generating debt
foreign
by the early 20th century the U.S had
already implemented and removed a few
Central Banking systems which were
maneuvered into place by ruthless
banking interests at this time the
dominant families in the banking and
business world were the Rockefellers the
Morgans the warburgs the Rothschilds and
then the early 1900s they sought to push
once again legislation to create another
Central Bank
however they knew the government and
public were very weary of such an
institution so they needed to create an
incident to affect public opinion
so JP Morgan publicly considered a
financial luminary at the time
exploited his Mass influence by
reportedly creating rumors that
prominent banks in New York were
insolvent or bankrupt Morgan knew this
would trigger Mass hysteria and a
systemic crisis and it did
the public and fear of losing their
deposits immediately began Mass
withdrawals consequently the banks were
forced to call in their loans causing
the recipients to sell their property
and thus a spiral of bankruptcies
repossessions and turmoil emerged
putting the pieces together years later
congressman Charles Lindbergh wrote The
King Bankers put in Motion in 1907 a
great scheme they had gambled and
speculated on Wall Street until so many
watered stocks and bonds had been
manufactured the king Bankers knew the
condition and informed the favorite of
their friends but was to come there was
to be a panic in the fall of 1907 and
that would be advertised as the result
of our bad Banking and currency laws
the Panic of 1907 led to a congressional
investigation headed by Senator Nelson
Aldrich who had intimate ties to the
financial powers and later became part
of the Rockefeller family through
marriage the commission led by Aldrich
recommended a central bank should be
implemented so a panic like 1907 could
never happen again this was the spark
that the bankers needed to initiate
their plan and in 1910 a secret meeting
was held at a J.P Morgan estate on
Jekyll Island off the coast of Georgia
it was there that the central banking
bill called the Federal Reserve Act was
written this legislation was written by
Bankers not lawmakers this meeting was
so secretive so concealed from
government and public knowledge that
most of the figures who attended
disguised their names when enroute to
the island and after this bill was
constructed it was then handed over to
their political front man Senator Nelson
Aldrich to push through Congress and in
1913 with heavy political sponsorship by
the bankers Woodrow Wilson became
president having already agreed to sign
that Federal Reserve Act in exchange for
campaign support and a few days before
Christmas when much of Congress was at
home with their families the Federal
Reserve Act was voted in and Wilson in
turn made it law
the night before its passage congressman
Charles Lindbergh pleaded this act
establishes the most gigantic Trust on
Earth when the president signs this act
the invisible government by the money
power will be legalized
now the public was told that the Federal
Reserve System was an economic
stabilizer and inflation and economic
crises were a thing of the past
well as history has shown nothing was
further from the truth the fact is the
bankers now had a streamed-line machine
for economic manipulation
[Music]
for example from 1914 to 1919 the FED
substantially increased the money supply
resulting in extensive loans to small
Banks and the public then in 1920 the
FED deliberately contracted Credit in an
extreme way thus resulting in Banks
having to call in large numbers of loans
and just like 1907 Bank runs bankruptcy
and systemic collapse occurred numerous
competitive Banks outside of the Federal
Reserve System collapsed further
consolidating the Monopoly of the money
trust cartel
thank you
privy to this scheme Congressman
Lindbergh pronounced under the Federal
Reserve Act panics are scientifically
created the present Panic is the first
scientifically created one worked out as
we figure a mathematical equation
however the Panic of 1920 was just a
warm-up
from 1921 to 1929 the FED again
increased the money supply resulting
once again in extensive loans to the
public and Banks there was also a fairly
new type of loan in the stock market the
broker call loan very simply this loan
allowed an investor to put down only a
fraction of the Stock's value with the
rest being loaned from the broker this
method was very popular in the Roaring
1920s as everyone seemed to be making
money in the market however there was a
catch to this loan it could be called in
at any time and had to be paid within 24
hours and the typical result was the
selling of the stock purchased with that
loan
so a few months before October in 1929
JD Rockefeller Bernard Baruch and many
other insiders quietly exited the market
knowing the bubble created was about to
burst
then on October 24th 1929 The financiers
Who furnished the call loans started
calling them in in Mass
this sparked an instantaneous massive
sell-off in the already inflated Market
has sell orders and margin calls were
systemically triggered that then led to
mass Bank runs eventually collapsing
thousands of banks enabling the large
Banks to buy up the now failed banks at
a discount
but it didn't stop there
rather than expanding the money supply
in order to recover from this economic
collapse the FED actually contracted it
fueling one of the largest depressions
in American history
outraged Congressman Lewis McFadden then
chairman of the house Banking Committee
filed petition for impeachment against
the Federal Reserve board
stating
Mr chairman we have in this country one
of the most corrupt institutions the
world has ever known I refer to the
Federal Reserve board and the Federal
Reserve Banks
this evil institution has impoverished
and ruined the people of the United
States and has practically bankrupted
our government it has done this through
the defects of the law under which it
operates through the male administration
of that law by the Federal Reserve board
and through the Corrupt Practices of the
moneyed vultures who control it
now having reduced the society to
squalor it was then decided that the
gold standard should be removed in order
to do this they needed to acquire the
remaining gold in the system so under
the pretense of helping to end the
Depression came the 1933 gold seizure
under the threat of imprisonment for 10
years everyone in America was required
to turn in all gold bullion to the
treasury essentially robbing the public
of what little wealth they had left and
at the end of 1933 the gold standard was
abolished if you look at a dollar bill
before 1933 it says it is redeemable in
Gold if you look at the dollar bill
today it says it is legal tender which
means it is backed by absolutely nothing
the only thing that gives our money
value is the public faith and how much
of it is in circulation
therefore the power to regulate the
money supply is also the power to
regulate its value which is also the
power to manipulate and control entire
economies
it is important to clearly understand
the Federal Reserve is a private
Corporation it is about as Federal as
Federal Express it makes its own
policies and is under little regulation
by the U.S government it is a private
bank that loans all the currency at
interest to the government completely
consistent with the Central Banking
model that the country sought to escape
from when it declared independence in
the American Revolutionary War now going
back to 1913 the Federal Reserve Act was
not the only Bill pushed through
Congress for the vested Financial
interests they also pushed its partner
the federal income tax
first of all the federal income tax is
completely unconstitutional as it is a
direct unapportioned tax and the
required number of states needed in
order to ratify the amendment to allow
the income tax was never legally met and
this has even been cited in modern court
cases
second at the present day roughly 25
percent of the average workers income is
taken from them via this tax that means
you work three months out of the year to
fulfill this tax obligation and where
does that money go
according to the grace commission report
to the 1980s 100 percent of what is
collected is absorbed solely by interest
on the federal debt and by federal
government contributions to transfer
payments in other words all individual
income tax revenues are gone before one
nickel is spent on the services which
taxpayers expect from their government
today the money Americans make working
three months out of the year goes almost
entirely to the interest fees charged
for the debt-based fiat currency
the fact is the federal income tax
exists to feed the Federal Reserve
federal government money machine making
sure the interest payments are always
there
and third even with the government claim
as to the legality of the income tax
there is still evidently no statute no
law in existence that requires you to
pay this tax I really expected that of
course there's a law that you can point
to in the law book the code that
requires you to file a tax return of
course there is I was at that point
where I couldn't find the statute that
clearly made it person liable
at least not me and most people I know
and I had no no choice in my mind except
to to resign based on the resources I
did throughout the year 2000 and that
I'm still doing I have not found that
law I've asked Congress we've asked a
lot of people in the IRS IRS
Commissioners helpers
they can't answer because if they answer
the American people are going to know
that this whole thing is a fraud
I haven't filed an income federal income
tax return since I left I have not filed
a tax return since 1999.
now the control of the economy and the
manipulation of society for the vested
Financial Powers is only a part of the
game being played
another level is the business of War
since the Inception of the Federal
Reserve in 1913 a number of large and
small Wars have commenced the three most
pronounced might be World War One World
War II and Vietnam World War One in 1914
European Wars broke out centered around
England and Germany the American public
wanted nothing to do with the war in
turn President Woodrow Wilson publicly
declared neutrality however under the
surface evidence now shows that the
financial Powers behind the
administration were looking for any
excuse it could to enter it it is
important to understand that one of the
most lucrative things that can happen
for the bankers is war for it forces the
country to borrow even more money at
interest not to mention the profits
generated through the financing of
military production in the words of
two-time Congressional Medal of Honor
winner Smedley D Butler war is a racket
it always has been it is possibly the
oldest easily the most profitable surely
the most vicious it is the only one
international in scope and it is is the
only one in which the prophets are
reckoned in dollars and the losses and
lives
Woodrow Wilson's top advisor and Mentor
was Colonel Edward house a man found to
have intimate connections with the
financial interests of the time in a
conversation with Colonel house Wilson's
advisor and Sir Edward gray the foreign
Secretary of England regarding America
and the war gray inquired what will
America do if Germans sink an ocean
liner with American passengers on board
house responded I believe that a flame
of indignation would sweep the United
States and that by itself would be
sufficient to carry us into war
so on May 7 1915 a ship called the
Lusitania was sent where German military
vessels were known to be
and as likely expected German U-boats
torpedoed the ship exploding stored
Munitions killing 1200 people
to further understand the obvious
anticipation of this setup the German
Embassy actually put advertisements in
the New York Times telling people that
if they boarded the Lusitania they did
So at their own risk as such a ship
sailing from America to England through
the war zone would be liable to
destruction in turn and as anticipated
the sinking of the Lusitania caused a
wave of anger among the American
population and America entered the war a
short time after
Major General Smedley D Butler
summarizes the monetary reality of World
War One
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
on December 7th 1941 Japan attacked the
American Fleet at Pearl Harbor
triggering U.S entry into that War
President Franklin D Roosevelt declared
the attack was a day that will live in
infamy a day of infamy indeed but not
because of the alleged surprise attack
on Pearl Harbor after 60 years of
surfacing information it is now clear
that Not only was the attack known well
in advance it was outright wanted and
provoked in a journal entry by
Roosevelt's secretary of War Henry
Stimson dated November 25th 1941. he
documented a conversation he had with
Roosevelt
question was how we should maneuver them
into firing the first shot at in
Congressional testimony later he added
it was desirable to make sure the
Japanese be the ones to do this so that
there should remain no doubt as to who
were the aggressors
in the months leading up to the attack
on Pearl Harbor Roosevelt had done
almost everything in his power to anger
the Japanese showing a posture of
aggression he halted all of Japan's
Imports of American petroleum he Froze
all Japanese Assets in the United States
he made public loans to nationalist
China and supplied military aid to the
British both enemies of Japan and the
war which by the way was in complete
violation of international War rules and
with numerous Japanese codes broken in
advance revealing the plan to attack on
December 7 1941 Japan was allowed to
attack Pearl Harbor killing 2 400
soldiers
before a Pearl Harbor 83 percent of the
American public wanted nothing to do
with the war after Pearl Harbor one
million men volunteered
it is important to note Nazi Germany's
war effort was largely supported by two
organizations one of which was called IG
farbin IG farben produced 84 percent of
Germany's explosives one of the unspoken
partners of IG farben was JD
rockefeller's Standard Oil company in
America in fact the German air force
could not operate without a special
additive patented by rockefeller's
Standard Oil the DraStic bombing of
London by Nazi Germany for example was
made possible by a 20 million dollar
sale of fuel to ig farvin by the
rockefeller's Standard Oil Company this
is just one small point on the topic of
how American Business funded both sides
of World War II
one other treasonous organization with
mentioning is the union banking
corporation of New York City not only
did they finance numerous aspects of
Hitler's rise to power along with actual
materials during the war it was also a
not seen money laundering bank which was
eventually exposed for having millions
of dollars of Nazi money in its faults
the union banking corporation of New
York was eventually seized for
violations of the trading with the Enemy
act guess who the director and vice
president of the Union Bank was
Prescott Bush the father and grandfather
of former U.S presidents George W bush
and George H.W bush
Vietnam the United States official
escalation and entry into the Vietnam
war came after an alleged incident
involving two U.S destroyers being
attacked by North Vietnamese PT boats in
the Gulf of Tonkin this is known as the
Gulf of Tonkin incident this situation
was the catalystic pretext for massive
troop deployment and full-fledged
Warfare
one problem however the attack on the
U.S destroyers by Vietnamese PT boats
never happened former Secretary of
Defense Robert McNamara stated years
later that the Gulf of Tongan incident
was a mistake while classified documents
released years later showed that it was
a farce manipulated for the purposes of
War
and once in the war it was business as
usual in October 1966 president Lyndon
Johnson lifted trade restrictions on the
Soviet Bloc knowing full well that the
Soviets were providing upwards of 80
percent of North Vietnam's War supplies
consequently the Rockefeller interests
financed factories in the Soviet Union
which the Soviets used to manufacture
military equipment and send to North
Vietnam
however the funding of both sides in
this conflict was only one side of the
coin in 1985 Vietnam's Rules of
Engagement were Declassified this
detailed with American troops were and
were not allowed to do in the war it
included such absurdities as North
Vietnamese anti-aircraft missile systems
could not be bombed until they were
known to be operational no enemy could
be pursued once they crossed the border
of Laos or Cambodia and most revealing
of all the most critical strategic
targets were not allowed to be attacked
unless initiated via High military
officials apart from these illogical
limitations North Vietnam was informed
of these restrictions and therefore
could base entire strategies around the
limitations of the American forces this
is why the war went on for so long and
the bottom line is this the Vietnam War
was never meant to be won just sustained
this war for profit and resources
resulted in 58 000 American deaths and 3
million dead Vietnamese
so where are we now
September 11th was the jump start for a
hegemonic agenda enabling the
possibility of constant Global Warfare
it was a staged War pretext no different
than the sinking of the Lusitania the
provoking of Pearl Harbor and the Gulf
of Tonkin live
in fact if 9 11 wasn't a planned War
pretext it would be an exception to the
rule it has been used to launch two
unprovoked illegal Wars one against Iraq
and the other against Afghanistan
however 911 was a pretext for another
War as well
the war against you the Patriot Act
Homeland Security the military tribunals
act and other legislations are all
completely designed to destroy your
civil liberties and protect those in
power
currently in the United States
unannounced to most Americans your home
can be searched without a warrant
without you being home you can in turn
be detained indefinitely with no charges
revealed to you
no access to a lawyer and legally
tortured all under the suspicion that
you might be a terrorist
if you need a painted picture of what is
happening let's recognize how history
repeats itself
in February 1933 Hitler staged a false
flag attack burning down his own German
Parliament building in the reichstag
blaming it on communist terrorists
within the next few weeks he passed the
enabling act which completely eradicated
the German Constitution destroying
people's liberties
he then led a series of preemptive Wars
all Justified as necessary to
maintaining Homeland Security
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
our enemy is a radical network of
terrorists
and every government that supports them
it's time to wake up the people in power
go out of their way to make sure you are
perpetually misled and manipulated
the majority's perception of reality
especially in the political arena is not
their own it is shrewdly imposed upon
them without them even knowing it
for example the public at large now
believes the invasions of Iraq and the
Middle East along with the resulting
instability are the consequences of
political and Military mistakes
what the public fails to see of course
is that the destabilization of the
Middle East is exactly what the Western
interests want
this war is to be sustained so the
region can be divided up domination of
the oil maintained continual profits
reaped for defense contractors and most
obviously permanent military base is
established to be used as launching pads
against other oil-bearing non-conforming
countries such as Iran
for further implication that the Civil
War and destabilization is purely
intentional in 2005 two Elite British
SAS officers were arrested by Iraqi
police after being caught driving around
in their car shooting at civilians while
dressed up as Arabs after being arrested
and taken to a jail in Basra the British
army immediately demanded beliefs of
these men when the Basra government
refused British tanks came in and
physically broke out the men from the
Basra prison if you wish to destroy an
area how do you do it well the two ways
you can go in there and vomit and so
forth but that is not very efficient
what you do is you try to get the people
in that area to kill each other and to
destroy their own territory
their own farms and that's what's been
done in that area the way in which you
destroy an opponent is get him to
destroy himself by dividing his ranks
against one another then you feed both
sides you have agents feeding both sides
inflaming both sides and they kill each
other off
and it's time that some of us woke up to
this reality
to understand
that people who try to maintain Empires
and great Empires
do it by manipulating the people they're
trying to conquer
you might want to ask yourself why the
entire culture is utterly saturated with
mass media entertainment from all sides
while the educational system in America
continues its stupefying downward slides
since the U.S government decided to take
over and subsidize the public school
system
what your government pays for it gets
when we understand that then we look at
government financed institutions of
education and see the kind of students
and the kind of education that's being
turned out by these government Finance
schools logic will tell you that if what
is being turned out in those schools was
not in accord with what the state and
the federal government wanted
then it would change it
the bottom line is that the government
is getting what they have ordered they
do not want your children to be educated
they do not want you to think too much
that is why our country and our world
has become so proliferated with
entertainments mass media television
shows amusement parks drugs alcohol and
every kind of entertainment to keep the
human mind entertained
so that you don't get in the way of
important people by doing too much
thinking
you have better wake up and understand
that there are people who are guiding
your life and you don't even know it
we're in a lot of trouble
because you people and 62 million other
Americans are listening to me right now
because less than three percent of you
people read books
because less than 15 percent of you read
newspapers because the only truth you
know is what you get over this tube
right now there is a hole an entire
generation that never knew anything that
didn't come out of this too
this tube is the gospel the ultimate
Revelation this tube can make or break
presidents popes Prime Ministers this
tube is the most awesome God damn force
in the whole Godless world and Woe Is Us
if it ever falls in the hands of the
wrong people and when the largest
company in the world controls the most
awesome goddamn propaganda force and the
whole Godless world who knows what [ __ ]
will be better for truth on this network
so you listen to me listen to me
television is not the truth
television is a goddamn amusement park
television is a circus a carnival a
traveling troop of acrobat story tell us
dancers singers jugglers Sideshow freaks
lion Tamers and football players we're
in the bottom killing business
but you people sit there day after day
night after night all ages colors creams
we're all you know you're beginning to
believe the Illusions we're spinning
here the other getting to think of the
tube is reality and that your own lives
are unreal you do whatever the tube
tells you to dress like a tube you ain't
like a tube you raise your children like
the cube you even think like the two
this is mass Madness you Maniacs in
God's name you people are the real thing
we are the illusion
the last thing the power establishment
wants is a conscious informed public
capable of critical thinking this is why
a continually fraudulent Zeitgeist is
output via religion the mass media and
the educational system it is in their
interest to keep you in a distracted
naive bubble
and they are doing a damn good job of it
[Music]
this is Aaron Russo a filmmaker and
former politician to his left is
Nicholas Rockefeller of the Council on
Foreign Relations
after maintaining a close friendship
with Nicholas Aaron eventually ended the
relationship appalled by what he had
learned
he said would you like to meet one of
the Rockefellers I said sure I'd love to
and uh we became friends and um began to
divulge a lot of things to me
so he said to me one night he said that
there's going to be an event there
and out of that event you're going to
see we're gonna go into Afghanistan so
we've run pipelines from the Caspian Sea
we're going to go into Iraq to take the
oil and establish a base in the Middle
East and we're going to go into
Venezuela and and try and get rid of
Chavez and uh the first two they've
accomplished events they didn't
accomplish and uh so you're gonna see
guys going to caves looking for
looking for people that they're never
gonna find you know he's laughing about
the fact that you have this war on
terror there's no real enemy he's
talking about how by having this war on
terror you can never win it because this
is an eternal war and so you can always
keep taking people's Liberties away and
I said how you can convince people that
this war is really but the media the
media is can convince everybody it's
real I mean you know it's just that you
keep talking about things you keep
saying it over and over and over again
and eventually people believe this you
know you created the star Reserve in
1913 through lies you create 911 which
is another lie through 9 11 you then
you're fighting a war on terror and now
also you go into Iraq which was another
lie and now they're going to do Iran you
know and so one thing leading to another
leading to another wheel to another now
I would say that why what are you doing
this for what what's the point of this
thing you have all the money in the
world you ever want you have all the
power I said you know you're hurting
people is it's not a good thing and he
would say well you care about the people
for take care of yourself and take care
of your family
and then I said so what else what are
the ultimate goals here to the goal the
ultimate goal is to get everybody in
this world chipped under the tree with
the RFID chip and uh have all money
Beyond those chips and everything on
those chips and if anybody wants to
protest what we do or violate what we
want we just turn off that ship
so how far will the sickness of power go
to what lengths will those in control go
in order to maintain and preserve their
positions
we have a Florida family who are really
Pioneers in A Brave New World they have
volunteered to be the first ever to have
microchip identification devices
implanted into their bodies after 9 11 I
was really concerned with the security
of my family
I wouldn't mind having something planted
permanently in my arm that would
identify me
George Orwell and his famed and possibly
prophetic work 1984 stated
power is not a means it is an end the
object of persecution is persecution the
objective torture is torture the object
of power is power
today symptoms of a surveillance Society
continue to grow as irrational fears of
invisible enemies coupled with Rising
economic instability spread across the
globe it is under this guise of security
that we can foreshadow a world where
everyone is tracked everyone is on
camera and everyone is subordinated
the most incredible aspect of all such
totalitarianism would likely not be
forced upon the people rather the people
will demand it
for the social manipulation of society
through the generation of fear and
division has completely inhibited the
culture
religion patriotism race wealth class
and every other form of arbitrary
separatist identification and thus
conceit has served to create a
controlled population utterly malleable
in the hands of the few
divide and conquer is the motto and as
long as people continue to see
themselves as separate from everything
else they lend themselves to being
completely enslaved
however the people ever realize the
truth of their relationship to Nature
and the truth of their personal power to
affect change the entire manufactured
Zeitgeist that's preyed upon would
collapse like a house of cards
[Music]
the whole system that we live in drills
into us that we're powerless that we're
weak that our society is evil that it's
private Etc and so forth it's all a big
fat lie we are powerful beautiful
extraordinary
there is no reason why we cannot
understand who we truly are where we are
going there is no reason why the average
individual cannot be fully empowered we
are incredibly powerful beings
and I think I spent 30 years of my life
the first 30 trying to become something
I want to become good at things I want
to become good at tennis I want to
become good at school and great and
everything I kind of viewed in that
perspective I'm not okay the way I am
but if I got good at things
you realize that I had the game wrong
the game was to find out what I already
was find out what I already was
[Music]
now in our culture we've been trained
for individual differences to stand out
so you look at each person immediately
it is brighter Dumber older younger
richer poorer and we make all these
dimensional distinctions put them into
categories and treat them that way and
we get so that we only see others as
separate from ourselves in the ways in
which they're separate and one of the
dramatic characteristics of experience
is being with another person and
suddenly seeing the ways in which they
are like you not different from you and
experiencing the fact for that which is
Essence in you and which is Essence in
me is indeed one the understanding that
there is no other it is all one
and I wasn't born Richard Albert I was
just born as a human being and then I
learned this whole business of who I am
and whether I'm good or bad or achieving
or not all that's learned along the way
[Music]
the old appeals to racial sexual and
religious chauvinism to rabid
nationalist fervor are beginning not to
work the new Consciousness is developing
which sees the Earth as a single
organism and recognizes that an organism
had war with itself is doomed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
used to finish his shows
with this
life's like a ride in an amusement park
and when you go on it you think it's
real because that's how powerful our
minds are
and the ride goes up and down and round
and round it has Thrills and chills and
it's very brightly colored and it's very
loud and it's fun for a while
some have been on the ride for a long
time and they begin to question is this
real Christmas just a ride
and other people have remembered and
they come back to us and they say hey
don't worry Don't Be Afraid ever
because this is just arrived
and we kill those people
shout him up I've got a lot of invested
in this right shut him up look at my
furrows of worry look at my big bank
account my family this has to be real
[Music]
it's just a ride
we will kill those good guys and try and
tell us that you ever notice that and
let the Demons Run among
it doesn't matter
because it's just a ride and we can
change it in time one it's only the
choice no effort no work no job no
savings or money
choice right now
between fear
and love
[Music]